hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled dna synthesis for mrna
therapeutics how to ensure good results
by choosing the right dna this webinar
is part of the 2021 microbiology virtual
week and i am susie valdez of leverage
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo fisher scientific for more
information about our sponsor please go
to thermofisher.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation and if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing these
presentations just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
now as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits
i now would like to introduce today's
speaker dr axel tresper the director of
research and development at thermo
fisher scientific
for a complete biography of our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr trester welcome you may now begin
your presentation um i'll be speaking
about dna synthesis for mrna
therapeutics and how to ensure good
results by choosing the right dna
today i'll cover
a number of different areas first i'll
give a brief introduction on who we are
at thumb official what we do
and then i'll talk about synthetic
biology and where it comes from some of
the background by
explaining how this brings engineering
to biology
and then i'll talk about one of the
secrets in synthetic biology synthetic
dna and in the end how this really
applies to mrna therapeutics
so
thermofisher who we are
we are
the industry leader in serving science
we are pretty large company with 80 000
employees and roughly 30 billion dollars
for annual revenue
there's a large commitment in the
organization to innovation and science
so
more than a billion dollars are invested
a large group of over well over 5 000
scientists and engineers are focused on
development and research
i think
the
goal of what we do is really lead in you
know the lead by developing leading
innovative technologies and to provide
deep application expertise to our
customers
and
scientists in the field to
move science forward
on the next slide you'll see some
examples and how we are set up basically
you know it's centered around four large
areas life science solutions specialty
diagnostics analytical instruments and
lab products and services
and the way to look at this is your left
products and services are a lot of the
things you use every day in the lab
analytical instruments are the big boxes
providing you with
in-depth analysis and
specific applications
in a number of areas specialty
diagnostics is a lot about
diagnosing
by diagnosing um pathogens and and other
items immune
immune markers and so on biomarkers
and in the life science solutions group
it's a lot around
different
reagents instruments workflows in life
science research centered around
recombinant dna
proteins antibodies and and all of those
things
we have a mission we are very proud of
which is we enable our customers to make
the world healthier cleaner and safer
and here a couple examples are given so
one example how we make the world safer
is really to
provide
in this case instrumentation
for
to ensure the quality and safety of
medicines
for cleaner we support in our innovative
research and development of cleaner more
efficient power sources and healthier we
play a
significant role in both
delivering diagnostic tests as well as
vaccine and therapy development and
production to fight the covet 19
pandemic globally
and this is really as i said a mission
we're proud of and also something that
makes me go to work every day and the
key aspect is really here we enable our
customers so we really want to
make it easier for you to do your
research
with that i want to move into
more background on synthetic biology and
what this really means in terms of you
know bringing engineering to biology
the
when we look at
biological research one key aspect
that's really changed a lot of things
over the last couple decades is
sequencing data and the exponential
growth sequencing data has provided
it follows moore's law and really has
accelerated
uh
our understanding of all kinds of life
on this planet whether it's plants
animals microbes what have you
and this in-depth understanding has
really enabled us to
move biology forward from a science
that's mostly centered around
observation
to a science that's more driven by
application
and this deep understanding of the
biological code at the center has really
driven a lot of that transition
when we look at this
[Music]
synthetic biology is a step in the
evolution of scientific of biological
research
and you know humans ever since we've
used biological systems and we've aimed
at developing biological systems with
desirable traits that started out with
you know classical breeding
and when you look at that it takes
a long time your centuries millennia to
develop
organisms which have the desired trait
over the last century accelerated
breeding was used
which
accelerated that whole process down to
decades
for the last 30 40 years genetic
engineering has played a predominant
role
to which again accelerated um
the way how we can produce biological
systems with desired phenotypes
and also has enabled us to generate
phenotypes and genotypes which go above
and beyond what nature really provides
and the way we look at synthetic biology
it's the next step of the evolution of
biological methods how to generate
desirable
phenotypes and it really accelerates
this
by
bringing a different mindset to biology
biology
and what i mean with this can also be
explained by this statement of synthetic
biology is trying to make biology easier
to engineer
and this engineering approach in biology
is a key aspect
and
this when you look at it can also be
exemplified by this classical
engineering cycle of design build test
when you think of
designing a biological solution
it really means that you have to take
your vision and you have to translate it
into
a biological code which in the end means
you have to translate it into dna
and this is also where we see our role
we've provided dna synthesis services
for the last 20 years and the key aspect
in this context is really you know you
have bioit solutions which enable you to
design
your
biological code that
encodes your vision
and then you need tools that enable you
to efficiently write that dna and this
is what we provide to our customers in
the market
ultimately
once you've encoded your vision in the
right dna you've embedded it in the
right organism you're able to then
basically follow this engineering cycle
you can build your prototype you can
test it you can redesign it and
ultimately you will have a system that
does what you want and has the phenotype
you want
while this may sound futuristic it is
actually not that futuristic anymore i
think it's something that's over the
last couple years has impacted many
areas in life sciences
and also beyond some of them are shown
here whether you talk about you know
truck development
agriculture
enable new bion technology like you know
the whole discussion around bio-based
fuels bio-based chemicals
uh vaccine research is something that's
really also being driven by some bio
obviously a lot of what we do in any
basic research
can be applied in any basic research
field
and last but not least all the synthetic
dna in writing synthetic biology and
writing dna has also enabled
new applications beyond life sciences
like dna for data storage
with that
i want to move into
talking some more about
you know synthetic dna and the secrets
behind it
um synthetic dna comes in a number of
different flavors and forms
um it can be you know linear it can be
cloned and it's basically a ready-to-use
plasmid
it can be provided in a
functional vector that can go right into
the application
or it can also be just linear fragments
that just encodes the dna and then
either has to be cloned or can be used
as a linear fragment
we also provide additional services like
larger scale plasmid production or
direct conver production of protein from
your target dna or in some cases you
know for directed evolution purposes
provide
pools of dna which encode a certain
amount of diversity which enables
screening of the right genotype of
phenotype
the underlying
product and how it's made is shown on
the next slide
in the end
anything we do around dna synthesis
really starts with the customer and the
researchers on your end
who uses a design tool bioinformatics to
design the right piece of dna in the
right construct it's
transmitted electronically it's ordered
we then produce it using custom
synthesis and then supply the final
product to you
all of the
detail in the middle
is shown on off to the right here
we again start with bioinformatics then
you know it's oligosynthesis we assemble
clone it
we confirm that it's correct by
sequencing provide the documentation
then we ship it to you
this workflow is again shown in some
more detail on here
what i find important is really in the
beginning bioinformatics does serve two
purposes
one is it enables us to
design a sequence in a way that we can
reliably and efficiently build it in the
minimal amount of time
at the same time it also enables
us or customers to design a sequence
that fit for purpose and the biological
function that you envisage
so you can actually optimize your
sequence for your function
the next step oligosynthesis is really
traditional chemical oligosynthesis so
you produ we produce short single
stranded oligonucleotides
which then in the gene assembly step get
assembled into double-stranded fragments
which are then cloned into a vector for
amplification and clonal isolation in
bacterial systems
and then
sequencing to confirm the correct
sequence and that it matches whatever
scientists and customers ordered in the
front end
we invest significant effort to
continuously drive efficiency and
improve our services accelerate the
service and and make it more seamless
for our customers
so one large area where we focus is
really to drive throughput and many by
miniaturization and automation
sequencing is actually a significant
bottleneck in the workflow so employing
high throughput sequencing mgs
sequencing really increases the service
level and accelerates the process
and in the end what this does it allows
us to deliver up to 12 000 bit
constructs up to 12 000 base pairs and
as little as five business days and as i
said earlier
if you need more than just your custom
sequence we can obviously also provide
it in your target vector and application
vector so it's ready to use and enables
you to think about your application and
your science and focus on that
and don't worry and don't deal with
the tedious
aspect of molecular cloning and handling
dna anymore
as i said bioinformatics plays a pivotal
role in this
and
not only
for us because it's critical for us to
design the sequences correctly for
production but also how to ensure
that
you get a sequence with
the best biological function
and i'll explain this some more in the
next couple slides
so one aspect is to really ensure that
you get the most out of your dna
and what that often means is that you
need to
really ensure that you get a high level
of expression or the ideal level of
expression of your target sequence
and so we've developed a methodology
which we call gene optimizer
which in mammalian systems and other
systems
provides you with an opportunity to
optimize for high protein expression
in this context we take into account
over 20 parameters
including codon usage gt content cryptic
spy supply sites known instability
sequences on a secondary structure
repeat and so on and so forth
by designing your sequence correctly we
can ensure that you get
the highest output possible
and
i'll show some data on the next slide
exemplifying this
i'll walk you through this in some more
detail so what we did here was take a
set of mammalian of human proteins
express them in the human cell line
we took a wide range of different
functions
representing highly expressed proteins
such as transcription factors ryan
personal proteins
low to medium expressed proteins certain
membrane proteins
which we have different folding kinetics
and also proteins or peptides which are
actually typically not expressed at all
like cytokines
and
what you can see in the western plot is
always in triplicates
wild type versus optimized
what you can see in all of these
examples and this is a subset of what's
published as a reference at the bottom
you can see that in all of those cases
we achieved the significant improvement
of expression and they i want to
emphasize we took human sequences and
expressed them in the human cell line
and we've seen this over and over again
also when we take hydrology sequences
that using our approach can really
ensure that you can
that you get good expression of your
target sequence
this
obviously
shows you how you can express biological
function
there are obviously
with that we
with that we also looked at how can we
[Music]
look at adding additional functionality
to your dna so not just the biological
function
and that's something i want to explain a
bit more in the next two slides
so when you look at digital media it's
actually possible to easily watermark a
document
and what watermarking really means
you embed a
message
into the media and the document which is
not visible to the user at a first place
and this is exemplified here using a
digital image
and if you take a small subset and this
is a grayscale image just for simplicity
purposes
you can see that each of these
grayscales comes with a number
and if i now want to encode i can take a
you know a simple ascii code which
consists of eight bits
and i can then basically look at if i
want to encode a certain message
i can slightly modify
this
grayscale the grayscale of different
pixels which then enables me to in this
image
encode a message by slightly altering
the coloring
but in the end when i look at the
complete
image i won't see that change
so this enables me to
encode a message
which is only
visible if i know a message is there
and i also know how the message was
encoded
and then i can go in and check for that
message decode it read it and understand
what it means
we were wondering whether you know
similar approaches can be applied to
dna and
um
what we did there was also to
is shown on the next slide
to look at how can we actually encode it
in the coding region so you know in the
yeah in a protein coding region because
that's typically the message or the part
of the protein
of a recombinant dna construct that is
required for its biological function
and the approach we took there was
to look at you know what's the
layer of information which we can adjust
without actually significantly altering
the biological function and
that's where we then started looking at
the genetic code and its redundancy
and when you look at the bottom right
you can see a subset of the human code
and usage table
and there's a number of amino acids
which are encoded by four or more
synonymous codons
and what we did there is that we
actually looked at the rank and used the
rank ordering to then encode a bit
and when you go to the top you can then
also basically by using these amino
acids
step through the coding region and by
slightly altering the coding region
without affection effect
affecting the biological function of the
complete construct and the complete
sequence
we can add a third layer of information
as a watermark and encode additional
information in a heterologous construct
you may wonder what this can be used for
it's actually
something that can be used in a variety
of ways so you could add you know brand
label or label vaccines or gene
therapies
you can incorporate
information on ownership origin
manufacturing date and what it really
does it ensures that your open breeding
frame or yours your target sequence can
be traced
without any doubt
where it goes whether it's
and you can always really go back and
verify that this is the sequence that
originated in your lab and in your
design
in addition it also will allow you to
clearly distinguish a synthetic sequence
from any possible wild type source
if you look at optimized sequences
optimized sequences differ from natural
sequences so you know in even just
optimization will actually do that but
you can also ensure that you take out
any doubt on that
and in our view in the long run
methods like this can also
guide us towards setting standards for
how do we actually
label these sequence label recombinant
sequences and gmos in a universal way
with that background on you know what's
writing dna and dna synthesis and
especially the aspects around the
design
i now want to move into
how this applies to mrna therapeutics
when we look at mrna therapeutics
we offer a wide range of different
aspects
and products that support this workflow
um
whether it's
all of the you know in the center all of
the reagents that go directly into
production
of the actual mrna or whether it's
downstream
um anything that you know it's needed
for purity for purification or
formulation
or upstream when we talk about you know
dna synthesis services to design your
target sequence which
is used
as input for the mrna production
or whether you talk about plasmid
production vector prep to produce it
i want to again center around dna
synthesis obviously because that's the
title and the purpose of the talk to
explain how that plays a role
in mrna therapeutics
and when we talk about this
it is really important to understand
that
how dna synthesis
plays a role in mrna therapeutics is
very much tied to the application
and obviously when we look at you know
what do mrna therapeutics do i think we
all know this and we all understand it
mrna therapeutics
are a way to reprogram cells for diverse
applications
um whether this is you know you
basically transfect the mrna and then
you produce some sort of protein in the
cells whether this protein becomes an
antigen which then allows you to
basically
use mrna as a vaccine
whether
you produce enzymes or cytokines which
then you know can overcome certain
limitations in uh in the body
whether you use
it to express cast 9 or guide rna to
change the genotype of a cell or car t
approaches
all of this can be achieved by mrna as a
modality and i think there's many more
ways to come in the future
the point i want to make is that
depending on your application
the approach
and how
you
supply the product is different which
then ultimately also in terms of what
you need
as input material at the dna level
is really different
and i want to use two examples from
the vaccine space
to illustrate that
one
if we look at something like covet which
obviously has driven a lot of interest
in mrna therapeutics over the last year
in the end it's really we deliver one
we you know in theory we deliver
one
template dna and one sequence
um
to basically eight billion people people
globally
and when you look at this in terms of
you know what does it mean for the input
dna the plasmid dna the dna synthesis
that happens
you need to synthesize one template dna
and then you need to provide hundreds of
kilograms of dna that can be used as
input for the mrna
and also you know the dna can be
produced on stock
so
there you basically have the challenge
of how do you scale it to that massive
scale that you can provide
mrna and you can provide the input
material globally to everyone who needs
it
when we look at the other at the other
end of the spectrum
i want to use cancer your antigen
immunotherapy as an example
it really start starts with a tumor
biopsy which is sequenced
and then it's being analyzed to identify
which mutations are present on the tumor
how does this allow you to select
epitopes which allow the immune system
to distinguish the tumor from healthy
cells
and then these neoantigens need to be
synthesized and efficiently delivered to
patients either via plasma dna viral
vectors or mrna
and then you know the challenge is very
different
in this particular case
typically
this is a personalized approach or often
this is personalized approach so
it's one treatment for one patient
also it becomes very time sensitive so
you know the the synthesis portion
needs to happen ideally in significantly
less than two weeks time
to enable that you know you can go from
biopsy to treatment for the patient in a
very
short period of time
to make sure that this happens before
that this happens in time for the
patient to benefit from the treatment
um
and this reprint represents very
different challenges on how to provide
the dna construct which i'll explain
some more in the next slide
when we look at how we actually do dna
synthesis
in the reo space which i explained a
little bit earlier we actually do this
in a very success sequential way we
start with design and then we move into
oligosynthesis assembly cloning do some
qc we scale it and we do final qc and
then we ship out to our customer
if anything goes wrong at any point in
time we do step back we repeat
you know we either step back one step or
multiple steps or even in some cases
have to go back
what that means is that and this is
shown by the blue line
that within the time window which we
offer to our customers for our services
we do not achieve 100 reliability
however when you look at personalized
therapeutics especially you know the
example i was just given giving
on
cancer immunotherapy
you obviously want to ensure that in the
promised time you deliver you as a
customer or researcher receive a hundred
percent of your constructs
so how do we get there and also how do
we actually achieve this in a time
that's significantly shorter than the
typical
time which we have for our uo constructs
that's shown on the next slide
i mean in the end it's pretty
straightforward we look at it
differently from a design perspective we
really make sure that we
design
that in the upfront
you know bioinformatics analysis we
really identify all of the potential
shortfalls and risks
and we stress them as early as possible
in addition to just our standard
synthesis approach
we actually right away start with a
backup option
we also as we move through the process
as much as possible run parallel options
not just you know we take one approach
we look at how it works and if necessary
we step back
we actually
often run parallel processes with
slightly different protocols or
complementary approaches to ensure
that in each step we achieve 100 percent
first time right to ensure that as we
step through it
everything is achieved in the shortest
time possible
in some cases we do parallel processing
um another point i want to make other
clarifies that when you move into
therapeutic
applications
typically
additional specifications apply compared
to typical cloning and research use only
so as early as possible we also
make sure that we address these
additional specs
we also provide
the options for extended qc
and in the end we also ensure that the
whole process is documented
our products at the moment are all iso
9001 certified we don't but again with
the extended documentation we have the
option to provide products which are
qualified to go into
further downstream processes
that can go into mrna therapeutics and
other therapeutic applications
and in the end this approach ensures
that in the shortest shortest amount
possible we can deliver
a
highly qualified product that well that
is well documented
and also at a very high reliability
which meets the needs for therapeutic
approaches as well
with that uh as i said you know we can
guarantee shortest turnaround time from
order to shipping
uh we have
at most order fulfillment and high
reliability of a hundred percent oops
and
also i want to again point out that you
know the
optional optimization we provide
can deliver you the highest in vivo
performance possible
also we provide the option to provide
additional genetic labeling branding
which allows you to really
trace all the way through the whole
process did anything change did anyone
actually steal my sequence
and again as i said we can actually
provide customer specific requirements
and you know any sort of special needs
around documentation whatever is
possible within the confines of our
current processes is something we can
provide
and again we have flexible flexibility
in our manufacturing scale
and can go up to
high microgram slash milligram
quantities of dna
and provide dna that's ready for
downstream processing in gmp
production
and
with that
i want to summarize i think you know
bringing engineering to biology allows
us to design the best functional
molecule for all biological applications
the secrets of synthetic dna really
provide us with control over these
complex processes and enabling new
approaches
and also ensuring that you as a
researcher and scientist get the best
possible dna for your
science
and this also enables us to
tailor this
to
support mrna
therapeutics
and
embed specific technologies in the
process to ensure that in the end you
have the best possible outcome of in
this space of mrna therapeutics
and with that
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you axel um so we already have a
few questions in already um we'll give
everyone else a few more minutes if you
want to start answering those um
everyone again if you want to